this is Startalk so welcome back to
Startalk yes Startalk live as you may
infer a feeble Marine Memorial Theatre
San Francisco California
that's Sketchfest 13th anniversary here
in 2014 is reckoned in the Common Era
and if you're just joining us I'm Bill
Nye the Science Guy CEO of the Planetary
Society sitting in for my dear friend
and colleague Neil deGrasse Tyson and
here on stage in this fabulous theater
and venue I have three other people our
regular Eugene Mirman is here visiting
from my coworker on Stargate Atlantis
among other things Dave Foley and a man
who really searches the heavens
listening for signs of life seth
shostack senior astronomer at the SETI
Institute if you remember last time
thank you we had a little input from the
audience thank you very much I will
press on so Seth I very much enjoy and
I'm fascinated by the history of the
search for extraterrestrial especially
the speculation about what's living
elsewhere but what's going on now in
search well what's going on now is that
we're continuing to do radio searches in
other words using big antennas to try
and eavesdrop on et where are these
antennas well the ones we use are about
300 miles north of where we're all
sitting here tonight in San Francisco so
they're up in the Cascade Mountains of
California for those of you who are
local you can just go up i v to reading
and it's a very interesting drive and
those who are local all right Dave was
Thanks just Texas Dave pull over
not while you're driving make a right
turn go for about an hour and a half
into the mountains there they're not
because of the cuisine they're there
because in fact it's shielded by these
mountains from all the you know radio
noise it's really effective in our
modern world of today in which we now
live that this hat Creek Valley is
noiseless or quiet it's not noiseless
but it's it's not because of noise from
cities like San Francisco actually it's
noisy simply because we now have
telecommunications satellites wheeling
overhead all the time and of course they
have transmitters and except they're in
outer space where they just go yes
because in outer space no one can hear
you boob so Seth in our first in our
first segment you asserted you claimed
that in the next 25 years we're gonna
get a signal well I didn't say that but
I will yeah well how are you gonna say
that well no I I said in this century
but I I think your numbers a good one I
think the next couple of dozen years may
do it and if you know why yeah well I
feel like maybe we're all fairly curious
I think Phil's ready to punch you over
this not over this okay Wow it's like
looking for a needle in a haystack if
somebody said look you know there's a
needle in a haystack over there and you
want to make an estimate how long it's
gonna take me to find that needle it
only depends on three things how big is
a haystack how fast are you going
through the hay and how many needles are
in there no in the case of looking for
et we know how that's it's pretty fast
talking so say again
needle a haystack of hubby's these
haystack is the entire known universe oh
heavens no heavens no get it huh
no so
so they so the haystack is is a trillion
planet is he gonna explain my jokes okay
it's it's the galaxy right if you if
there isn't any other intelligent life
in the galaxy maybe why look at another
galaxy right it's like saying you think
there any other mammals in North America
and if it turns out there aren't any it
doesn't really pay to also look in South
America well so unless you're talking
about the year negative 20 I meant to
say like ten thousand a CD negative
twenty yeah
dr. starry sauce yeah yeah okay I'll
finish this up this this ideas it's too
complex apparently but look so you need
to know how big is a haystack how fast
you going through it how many needles
are in there in the case of looking for
et the haystack is our galaxy let's look
in our got 200 billion stars roughly
plus or minus three right
how fast are we going through the hey
that we know that's that's a technical
question and we know how quickly we'll
go through the hay for the next ten or
twenty years as well that you can sort
of predict how well are a second and no
nothing like a star a second but the
speed actually follows something that's
a very famous relationship here near the
Silicon Valley namely Moore's law in
other words it doubles in speed every 18
months so that will continue for another
decade or two the only thing you don't
know is how many needles are in there
yeah I mean you know how many aliens are
in there but they're people people
who've guests like Carl Sagan is guess
Isaac Asimov guest you know Frank Drake
is guest guest Ujjain I have 80 but
what's your guess that's gonna be more
accurate eighty maybe good Eugene I may
not know but if it isn't at least a few
thousand news it's gonna take longer but
if it's as many as ten thousand right
twenty thousand stars with planets that
are habitable and so on not only
habitable but there's some inhabitants
but they'd have to be at our level of
technological and you know they can be
more advanced because I'm sorry but they
couldn't how much less than us could
they be not much okay
fifty years weird weird the basic we
gone where the people were like years
the negatives at least be it like the
Marconi phase yeah or Tesla if you want
to really be honest about it they would
have to have meconium was a [ __ ]
[ __ ] Tesla believed in this yeah he
did Tesla thought he'd heard the
Martians Nikola Tesla after whom what's
a Tesla anyone they named him a fair car
it's a Webber per square meter
a delicious salami I know that's not
true Jesus people he's good with
sauerkraut but he was a guy who after
whom we have a magnetic unit of flux
named yes and he was the guy who
pioneered direct current energy
transmission and the crazy alternating
yeah alternating alternating current
transmission right through the air and
all that everybody's just gonna glow
yeah and along with that he speculated
well he built this big Tower for his
wireless power transmission scheme which
by the way did work the trouble is it
also conveyed power to your hair
everything else but but he eventually
built the generators you know this it
Niagara Falls that was the important
thing for Westinghouse a bit of
electrical engineering history do good
for and he and Edison were dread enemies
killing elephants left and right that's
readable but okay okay any case Tesla
had this big tower outside in Colorado I
think was Fort Collins but any gates and
the idea was he was doing these
experiments and he found he found these
signals coming in on a radio signals and
he thought these are the Martians that
was sort of jumping to conclusions
probably they were what are called
whistlers which are caused by electrical
storms that just produce you know
electromagnetic disturbances radio waves
in the atmosphere the propagation right
from lightning while you're while you're
producing light not the margins it was
like you produce sprites and radio waves
and stuff so he was wrong about that he
was wrong about that yeah but and that's
why he was the greatest astronomer ever
well I'm gonna point something out to
you today but the risk of being too
serious here but any scientist who's
never made a mistake is probably not a
great scientist yeah but also a
scientist that only found Uranus is
simply pretty good yeah but it's not all
he found Oh what else did he but he did
all right I can't tell who was more
sexual based on your reaction and than
his lab so we I remember very well I was
in Carl Sagan's astronomy class I know
some of you are skeptical if what I'm
sure it was some sort of clerical error
at the University but I was in the class
and he's they speculated at that time
that about one in a hundred stars would
have planets and now we speculate that
every star has a planet or two or eight
or more and that one out of five has an
earth-like planet is that right Seth is
that number it was indeed a result
announced a couple of months ago days
all right
you don't have to sound so that's why I
am a terrible astronomer
this was an analysis done by some guys
at a state institution across the bay or
the name escapes me
but they they published this result they
did a preliminary analysis if you're
scoring along with us it's University of
California Berkeley and their estimate
was that sun-like stars maybe you know
thirty forty percent of them might have
an earth-like world twenty to forty
percent red dwarf stars which dominate
the heavens dominate runty guys
somewhere between maybe fifteen percent
and forty fifty percent of them might
have a habitable planet so bottom line
you average it all together you wait by
the number off Li one in five stars well
now you have a planet about a planet
that might be salubrious enough for you
to go into the business of constructing
condos on it because it would have you
know liquid oceans and maybe some air so
if you have two hundred billion stars in
our galaxy that's that's a lot of 40
billion 40 billion in our galaxy right
if you start telling the universe you
get into it's just weather intelligence
evolved on any of them yeah and life
alive is that a fear is that something
we should be afraid of that evolved a
dead intelligence well Eugene look at it
this way I mean we said earlier that one
of the great advances of this century
probably the thing that people will
remember the most about this century
they remembered at all is that we
invented Thinking Machines now how do
you think I figured I Lindsay Lohan you
might yes you will but not five hundred
years now toads that can write notes no
I know I could have said camera but once
you do that once you build a thinking
machine the first thing you ask is you
design something smarter than you are
and then yes that machine you design
something smart and you are and within
twenty years you have a machine that's
smarter than all you and Spiti guy so
why Centauri good thing I don't know I
know if it's a good thing but it's an
inevitable thing and the point is that
most of the intelligence out there is
probably synthetic and probably there
you know synthetic brain somewhere they
well yeah yeah somewhere back in the
past we were soft and squishy and
organic that must have been terrible
oh wait so you're saying whatever life
was there died but had first created
something smart they kept creating
smarter things and you know they don't
have to die but wait so there might be a
lot also there but anyway there could be
super smart intelligence that is
artificial that has now moved on the
another planet had a thing just so story
but in other words we build computers so
we infer that we figured that somebody
everybody else is building computers
building machines smarter than they are
yeah you're right that maybe it's just
so storia maybe 99 out of 100 100 of
them don't do that they just sit around
with their wheeze or contemplating their
navel or whatever they're doing okay
those are the only two options you just
simplified my life but if one of them
does it you see that intelligence
becomes so incredible that it really
doesn't matter what the others do yes so
tell us about that
we what happens to the earth when we
just get a signal well most people he
walked the streets of San Francisco and
you asked people what do you think would
happen if scientists three hundred miles
north you pick up a signal most people
say well the government would shut it
all down and really give you a 90-minute
speech about organic food they're
monsters
that's what the public things say they
think it would all be kept quiet and
when I ask them why do you think that
they say because the public couldn't
handle the news doo doo doo doo doo doo
doo could you handle the news if you
picked up your newspaper tomorrow you
won't do that picked up your browser
tomorrow and you read you know
scientists fine signal coming from 800
light years away would you say that's it
I'm not going to work today would you
ride in the streets no you wouldn't do
any of that we have historical precedent
you wouldn't do that it would just be
very interesting story so sure we
wouldn't have to burn somebody at the
state oh yes
somebody would somewhere fine we would
murder one direction so because that our
arts were good so I claim it would dare
I say it change the world it would be
humans would be humbled yet again but
already most people believe aliens are
already visiting the earth you're
talking about my old boss most people
believe that yeah how many people watch
that show how many people watch this
show which one which ancient aliens oh
that's horrible yeah
no show called misinformation but if we
if we heard most people just well that
may be part of the reason why they
wouldn't write in the streets yeah we're
already here that people are fat and
lazy not like the old days when they do
riot in the streets apparently there
were never those old days really I mean
there's always ruin all about it
pitchforks and so ever I think most
people were you know going to a night
restaurant or whatever they weren't
bothering liberal but so what would
actually happen is it would simply be a
very interesting story if you could
understand anything
we're saying now that would be good
because remember they can't be less
until in Manson York because they're not
making any radio waves that we could
pick up so they're at least at our level
and it's very unlikely that they're
within a hundred years of our level they
did they'd be thousands millions
conceivably billions of years more
advanced suppose you could get
information from a society that's
millions of years more advanced than
ours right here's the cure for death
here's how to get along whatever now
would that be interesting or would you
say no I'm just gonna ride in the
streets yeah yeah that's state oh yeah
no it's working yeah I was gonna say
that is a very hopeful view you're like
here's here's how did not how to avoid
death and all that but they could also
come here and be like you now do all our
chores
what if they show up here at the same
time that the Lakers win a championship
and they think the riot is about them
well there's no shortage of unrest so
what is so fantastic seriously everybody
about this pursuit to me and really you
know what I'm involved in I'll be it in
the peripheral Way circumferential way
is that going to Mars exploring space
sending spacecraft to Saturn spacecraft
we hope to Europa and Titan these are
moons of Jupiter and Saturn respectively
is that it's optimistic there's this
thing within us that that that the
future is gonna be better and we're
gonna build spacecraft and we're gonna
look out there and find out what's going
on because the more we learn about our
solar systemic neighborhood the better
off we're gonna be and the more we learn
about radio signals in our galaxy the
better off we're going to be and that is
still something that I I think drives
all of us is this this optimism
through space exploration well okay
Thank You Eugene but you know if you're
not sure no but how close so how close
is in lightyears is the closest
inhabitable planet or earth-like planet
can you hold that thought I literally
can't
no problem because it's because we here
we are we're going to where we're at the
Marine Memorial Theatre at Sketchfest 13
in San Francisco California USA star
talk radio live and we are going to take
a break we'll be right back